Hey, everybody, and welcome
back to the "Mobile Ads Garage"
where we get into
mobile ads code the way
I get into pie eating contests.
Elbow deep.
So last time out we, coded
up a simple banner ad
implementation.
Today we're going to expand on
that by talking about the best
ways to use banners--
where to put them,
how they should
behave, and how you
can monetize while maintaining
a great user experience.
With me as always Gary The
Graphics Guy who's still
a little mad I took the last
slice of pizza at lunch,
but we're ready
to have some fun.
We get a lot of
questions on our forum
and in person about AdMob
policy, things like can I
put my ad view in a
list view, or is it
OK for this banner to be
next to this UI button?
We'll talk about those kind
of specifics in a second,
but first, I think
it'll help of everybody
understands why we have those
policies in the first place,
where they come from.
So let's bring it in and
have a serious moment.
[DRAMATIC MUSIC]
The main purpose
of AdMob's policies
regarding where to put
ads and when to show them
is to make sure that
every ad impression-- that
means every time an
ad is displayed--
is a good, honest impression,
and that every clickthrough is
a good, honest clickthrough.
We do this because
when ads are shown,
when a user taps on an ad, an
advertiser gets charged for it.
Somebody, somewhere--
could be a big company,
could be Aunt
Betty's Sweater Shop
For Beautiful Cats-- somebody
has to write a check.
And we need to be able to
tell Aunt Betty that every ad
impression she paid for was
an honest chance for somebody
to see her ad and that every
clickthrough came from someone
who was genuinely interested
in getting a sweater for Little
Miss Whiskerson.
So if you're ever in doubt about
whether a particular layout
or behavior is likely to
conflict with AdMob policy,
a great first step
is to ask yourself
would it interfere
with honest impressions
or honest clickthroughs,
and then put yourself
in Aunt Betty's shoes.
[MEOW]
Exactly.
So, there's our serious moment.
Now let's talk specifics.
Let's start with
an app like the one
from our first episode, just
a banner ad across the bottom.
Perfect.
This is a great layout
used buy a ton of apps.
The banner's visible, it's
not near any other controls,
and there's lots of
room for content.
Plus the user has plenty of
opportunity to see the ad,
and it's unlikely
that they'll tap on it
for any reason other
than being interested.
Excellent.
But watch what happens when I
add a button right down here.
Those are really close.
If you're going
for the button, you
might hit the ad by accident,
especially if you're like me,
and you have these big,
stupid caveman hands.
Gary, the last
slice is fair game.
Everyone knows this.
So this layout runs the risk
of a bad clickthrough, someone
accidentally tapping on
the ad when they really
want the button.
It's a common problem
but it's easy to fix.
You could just add a little
space or move the button.
Whatever you need
to do to make sure
the user isn't going to
tap the ad accidentally.
I've used buttons
in this example
but the principle applies to any
UI elements that accept input.
Another issue we
get questions about
is whether it's OK to ask users
to tap on ads, and it's not.
For example, if I were to
drop a UI label or a text view
in here, I'm giving
my users a reason
to click the ad even if
they're not interested,
and every clickthrough
costs money.
That means Aunt Betty
is going to end up
paying for clickthroughs
by people who aren't
interested in her cat sweaters.
That's going to hurt
her small business.
All right, let's get
rid of that and add
something else, a second ad.
Whoa!
In addition to crowding out
content and annoying our user,
we've also got bad impressions.
With two ads on
the screen at once,
they have to split the
spotlight, which isn't what
our advertisers signed up for.
The fix for this?
Just stick with one banner.
Ah, nice and simple.
That's what I like.
Hey!
I eat an appropriate amount
of pizza for an active person!
As I think we all learned during
off-site miniature golf team
building day, this is
an athlete, all right?
This is what sports looks like.
Moving on, some types of content
can also cause bad impressions.
Displaying a banner while
the user is actively playing
an action game, for example.
If I'm saving the world
from the forces of evil,
I'm probably too busy
to consider an ad even
when I might be
interested in it.
Just move the banner to
the menu or pause screen,
or consider using interstitials
between levels instead.
Another good thing to
avoid is loading banners
that aren't on screen yet.
This is a big reason
why we recommend
you don't place banners inside
list view or other scrolling UI
elements.
Every time an AdMob
banner is loaded,
an impression is recorded for
it even if it's off screen
or the user was scrolling so
fast they couldn't see it.
All right so that's
some stuff to avoid,
but you might be wondering what
are some things I should do?
What are the good practices?
One of the best things you can
do for your user experience
is to keep in mind
that ads should
live alongside your
content rather than being
mixed in with it.
Dedicate a spot for
them in your layout
away from UI inputs and outside
of scrolling content regions.
Doesn't matter if it's
the bottom or the top.
That way, you can be
fair to your advertisers
and make sure you don't annoy
your users by covering up
content.
Yes, thank you, Gary.
That's a great example of how
poor ad placement takes away
from the user experience.
Very funny.
Seriously?
You're going to body
shame in front of YouTube?
What's next, an ad for the
Pudgy Redhead Dating Network?
Oh, you can go--
[BLEEP]
Hey, everybody.
Sorry for blowing
my top like that.
Gary and I eventually
patched things up,
but it reminded me of one more
thing I wanted to mention.
There are types of
content that shouldn't
be included in any app
that displays AdMob ads.
Stuff like drug or
tobacco references,
racist hate speech,
adult content, and so on.
You can see this Help Center
article for more information
on prohibited content,
and the one below it
covers layouts and some of the
other things we talked about.
You might also like
AdMob's "No Nonsense Guide
To App Monetization."
It's an overview of
monetization strategies
it includes code and
tips other engineers.
As always, if you've got a
technical question relating
to anything you've just seen,
stop by our support forum.
And if you've got a question
about this video series
or an idea for something
we could cover,
leave a comment below, and Gary
and I will see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]